have you ever taken on five armed guards
with your hands tied behind your back or
pulled a woman from a moving helicopter
while having a knife lodged in your arm
if this sounds insane well it's just a
regular day for Jack Reacher yes we've
come to the thrilling conclusion of
Reacher season 2 based on the 11th entry
in the series bad luck and trouble in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into season 2 Shane Langston's plot to
sell missiles and where Reacher could be
headed for season 3 so if you haven't
already make sure to like And subscribe
and leave a comment about what you
thought of the season the events of
season 2 have led us here the research
and development facility owned by
aerospace engineering company New Age
Technology a rogue element within the
company director of security Shane
Langston has devised a plan to sell
Cutting Edge surfac to- a missiles worth
$65 million to an international arms
dealer known simply as am and Langston
would have gotten away with it if it
weren't for former special investigator
Tony Swan you see when new age director
of operations Marlo Burns found out that
Shane Langston was hiring all his former
police buddies officers who were under
investigation from internal affairs she
hired Tony Swan to do some digging Tony
had previously worked under Jack Reacher
as part of the military's special
Investigation Unit A unit that's
specialized in military crimes
throughout the season we'll see this
team come together in Implement
operation kit Runner a 2-year
investigation into Military Officers
smuggling heroin out of Afghanistan
this culminates in Reacher going against
direct orders and busting these bad guys
anyway which ends up with him and his
soldiers getting discharged several
years pass and the SIU members go about
their lives that is until Reacher
receives a call from former member
Francis Neely that several of the team
have been deliberately targeted and
killed this is what season 2 is all
about who is killing the members of the
SIU and why Reacher's investigation sees
him teaming up with what's left of his
team Neely odonnell and Dixon and
throughout the season's 8 episode span
we uncover an elaborate plan devised by
Langston it all starts with a defense
contract given to new age called little
WI a code name for a new anti-missile
software technology its purpose was
completely defensive in nature to
protect commercial aircraft from
missiles but Langston knew this Tech
could be tweaked into something
offensive into something truly
devastating with the help of Senator
Lavoy funding was buried in an
Appropriations Bill and new age got the
money it desperately needed of course a
company as big as new age can't be going
around selling USF funded missiles to
International arms dealers at least they
can't do it without someone noticing so
Langston develops an elaborate plan
remember that new age has two facilities
one in New York which makes the
microchips and one in Colorado which
produces the actual missiles only when
these two are combined do the missiles
work so months prior to Langston's deal
with am he had an engineer purposely
manipulate the data on defective chips
only to set them aside to be
reprogrammed with this illegal
weaponized software this would turn
these defensive missiles into portable
surface to- a weapons that could take
down anything with a 100% accuracy what
makes them particularly effective is
that they purposely miss their target at
first shot making the pilot think they
dodged it but the software allows the
missiles to reprogram themselves midair
and attack again we'll see this at work
at the very end when Neely blows up the
chopper with the pilot and engineer on
board two people who were complicit in
the sale of these weapons to terrorists
Langston gets am someone not associated
with new age to steal the missiles while
on route from Colorado allowing Langston
to take his tweaked microchips and
complete the deal in exchange for these
missiles Langston would receive 65
million in untraceable bonds money that
would be split with his henchmen and
then live out the rest of his days on a
beach somewhere of course Reacher won't
allow these weapons into the hands of
Terrace and must stop Langston before
this deal is done this brings us to the
finale where Reacher has agreed to turn
himself into Langston so that his
captured partners odonnell and Dixon are
kept safe Reacher and his team have been
a thorn in Langston's side the entire
season and by having them under lock and
key Langston hopes to finish his
transaction without any further
interference but Reacher has a couple
tricks up his sleeve first he told
Langston that Neely was killed by one of
his men last episode a lie so that she
could keep watch over the facility while
Reacher went inside died second Reacher
called in a favor from Senator Lavoy to
use three of his military units you
might remember these guys as his
bodyguards in episode 5 the last thing
the senator wants is for his involvement
in all this to be uncovered he didn't
think that this Tech would eventually
end up in the hands of terrorists thus
he gives Reacher his guards to take down
Langston third Reacher hid a brass
Fastener in his shoe which he'll later
use to free himself from his cuffs it
isn't long before Langston realizes that
neie is still alive if if he wants to
make sure all loose ends are tied she's
going to have to be killed too and the
only person who knows where she is is
Reacher and when Reacher won't tell him
he shows him Tony Swan's eyeball an
eyeball saved for retina scans to access
confidential information Langston was
going to make it look like Tony signed
off and all the paperwork masterminded
the whole deal and ran off with the
money meanwhile Dixon and odonnell are
loaded onto the chopper to meet the same
fate their former colleague Calvin
France who in episode one was thrown out
of luckily a combined effort from Neely
Lavoy team and Reacher who used his
Fastener to break free sees Reacher
making it to the chopper in the nick of
time and it's a good thing he gets there
as he saves Dixon from almost going over
and take a look at how strong Reacher is
holding on to the weight of Dixon in the
gurnie while a knife is lodged in his
arm getting kicked by Langston and later
a 200 plus pound dude on his back it's
pretty cool that Dixon's able to release
herself from the gurnie and pulls the
knife out of Reacher's arm to attack
just some insane action and Langston
receives a most ironic ending getting
thrown from the plane just like he
killed the other members of the SIU but
with Langston dead that still leaves am
and his delivery of missiles thankfully
the pilot of the chopper knows the
coordinates of Langston's Rendevous with
am and the team is able to pay him a
surprise visit now they give am a brief
moment to explain himself and the guy
has no remorse or guilt for what he does
sell arms to terrorist groups who use
them to kill his rationale is that he's
merely the middleman he's not the one
actually pulling the trigger and you can
tell by
this that answer isn't going to fly both
the engineer who put in the chips and
the pilot who flew the plane that killed
Reacher's teammates beg for their lives
both of them claiming they were just
doing their jobs but these guys both
totally knew what they were doing so
Neely demonstrates how one of these
$100,000 missiles works but it wouldn't
be a Reacher season without a Twist
turns out senator Lavoy agents have
orders of their own to kill Reacher and
his team to avoid risking one of them
talking and exposing the senator but
Reacher is one step ahead he knew Lavoy
would turn him thus he called Omar
Kareem of Homeland Security the man he
talked to in episode 5 Reacher even gets
the pleasure of calling Senator Lavoy to
tell him the bad news hearing him get
arrested on the other line now Reacher
tells Kareem he has no idea where that
money am was holding on to and Kareem
lets this Slide the money of course is
with creature in the form of these
untraceable bear bonds he'll use it to
make up for the pain this whole
situation has caused and there's
something nice about season 2 ending at
a diner much like season 1 although I
did keep an eye out for a Lee Child
Cameo on the television we can see that
homeland security has covered up the
chopper attack stating that it was
either a malfunction or Pilot error
there's even a reference to a sardian
president passing away which is a
fictitious European country found in
Scorpion and Fubar which Reacher
showrunner Nick santur also worked on we
get a little Montage of what Reacher did
with this money some went to Calvin fr's
wife and child Russo's nephews Sanchez's
girlfriend orosco's sister ne's father
and even the local animal shelter got a
bunch of cash in honor of Tony Swan's
dog Dixon gets enough money to start her
own business and o'donal's kids will
never have to worry about paying tuition
ever again but what does Reacher want
honestly just a toothbrush but why would
Reacher turn down not only this money
but a woman who loves cares for him
remember he also turned down a
relationship with Rosco in season 1
that's because for Reacher ultimate
freedom is not being tied down whether
that be with money or relationships and
this is something Dixon understands
about him the gang takes a picture
mimicking the one they took years ago as
members of the SIU now there is one
thing Reacher did purchase an annual
trailsway pass that lets him ride
anywhere in America as much as he wants
neie hopes that Reacher knows they're
more than just friends that that they're
family but Reacher doesn't acknowledge
this only when he's across from this old
man does he say he's coming from
visiting family while Reacher may have a
hard time expressing his feelings we
know deep down he cares about those
close to him but where will next season
take us the finale leaves us with a
clean slate we do know that season 3 has
been greenlit and production of it
actually started in the summer in
Toronto that's right you're on the set
of season 3 ARA right now Alan richson
even posted this photo of of him on set
but with the writers and actor strict
production was pushed just what Reacher
book will be adapted is yet to be known
but there are a whopping 28 to choose
from the books aren't exactly written in
chronological order so it's possible a
new season might take place before the
events of season 1 or two anything is
possible but what did you think of
Reacher season 2 I want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you like these types of videos be sure
to like And subscribe I cover all sorts
of shows and I'm now getting into True
Detective thanks for watching if you
want even more bad takes make sure to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram @
thinkstory YT until next time remember
he was stopped by barbecue he died from
trans
fats